S
TODAY, MOLLY HEMINGWAY AND
VICTOR DAVIS HANSON.
I WANT TO SAY A FEW THINGS
THERE ARE A SERIES OF
QUESTIONS ON WHETHER JOE
BIDEN USED HIS PUBLIC OFFICE
AND POSITION TO ENRICH
HIMSELF AND HIS FAMILY TO
OVER 30 MILLION DOLLARS.
WHY HE AND FAMILY MEMBERS
RECEIVED MILLIONS, STEPS OF
MILLIONS, FROM FOREIGN
GOVERNMENTS AND FRONT
CORPORATIONSES IN CHINA,
RUSSIA, UKRAINE.
AND OTHER PLACES.
WE HAVE HUNTER BIDEN LAPTOP,
LOADED WITH EVIDENCE.
THAT THE FBI IS ALL BUT
IGNORED AND MEDIA COVERED
UP.
WE HAVE WITNESSES LIKE BOB
WALENSKY ON THE RECORD
PUBLICLY AND DID A INTERVIEW
AND NEVER CONTACTED AGAIN.
YOU HAVE OTHER POTENTIAL
WITNESSES AND ACTORS WHO ARE
NAMED IN THE E-MAILS, AND
YOU HAVE DATES, AND TIMES,
AND TRANSACTIONS.
REALLY ANYTHING YOU WOULD
NEED.
AND WE HAVE TREASURY SAR
REPORTS, THEY ARE SUSPICIOUS
ACTIVITY REPORTS ON WIRED
FUNDS.
WHICH SHOULD GIVE YOU A LOT
OF INFORMATION, JOE BIDEN
SAID DURING THE COURSE OF
THE CAMPAIGN AGAINST DONALD
TRUMP, HE HAS NEVER
DISCUSSED HUNTER'S OVERSEA'S
BUSINESS DEALINGS, JOE BIDEN
IS A PATHOLOGICAL LIAR, HE
DID.
SO-CALLED EXPERTS WHO WERE
ROOTING FOR JOE BIDEN CLAIM
THAT LAPTOP WAS RUSSIA
DISINFORMATION.
THEY ARE LIARS.
FBI WARNED ABOUT RUSSIA
DISINFORMATION AT THE SAME
TIME THAT THE LAPTOP WAS AN
ISSUE BEFORE THE 2020
ELECTION MET WITH TWITTER,
WE NOW KNOW THAT, WITH
FACEBOOK, IN OTHER WORDS
THEY TRIED TO WAVE OFF BIG
TECH AND OLIGARCHS FROM THE
LAPTOP STORY, FBI HAD THE
LAPTOP FOR NEARLY A
YEAR, THE BIG GUY.
E-MAIL, MAY 13, 2017, REAL
EVIDENCE, WHO IS THAT.
>> THAT JOE BIDEN.
10% FOR THE BIG GUY.
10% FOR WHO?
FOR JOE BIDEN, IN THE
LAPTOP, I'M NOT MAKING IT
UP, WE KNOW THAT ACCOUNTS
AND FINANCES WERE
COMMINGLED.
HUNTER'S AND JOE'S AND00
HUNTER WOULD PAY FOR
THINGS FOR JOE, DID JOE PAY
TAXES ON THAT.
HOW ABOUT JOE BIDEN HAS HE
REPORTED THE GIFTS?
I DON'T THINK SO,
WHISTLE
BLOWERS, AND PICTURES WITH
JOE BIDEN, WITH HUNTERS
PARTNERS, THESE RAISE
CRIMINAL ISSUES, NOT SAYING
THEY ARE GUILTY BUT CRAZE
CRIMINAL ISSUES -- RAISE
CRIMINAL ISSUES.
OF WIRE FRAUD.
WHY DOES THIS MATTER?
THERE IS MORE.
TAXES.
JOE BIDEN PRIDES HIMSELF TO
RELEASING HIS INDIVIDUAL
INCOME TAXES AND HE HAS BEEN
CELEBRATED FOR THIS AND
TAKEN SHOTS AT DONALD
TRUMP FOR THIS COULD BE
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN HAS NOT
REALLY RELEASED ALL OF HIS
TAXES, HAS HE, CHRIS JACOBS
IN "WALL STREET JOURNAL" A
SHORT TIME AGO, IN 2017 AND
18 BIDENS AND HIS WIFE JILL
AVOIDED PAYROLL TAXES ON
FROM BOOK ROYALTIES AND
SPEAKING FEES.
THEY PAID THEMSELVES
SALARIES.
BUT THEY
CIRCUMVENTED THE PAYROLL
TAXES AND OBAMA CHARACTER
TAXES, THEY PROTECTED 95
PERCENT OF THEIR INCOME.
SO, MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
PROTECTED FROM THE PAYROLL
TAX THAT IS ALMOST A HALF
MILLION IN TAXES
THEY WOULD HAVE PAID.
THEY CITED BIDEN CAMPAIGN
WEB SITE.
WE DON'T KNOW.
THE QUESTION IS.
I DON'T HAVE THE ANSWER.
IF THEY WANT TO PROVE US
STUPID, WHY NOT RELEASE THE
S-CORPORATION TAX RETURNS.
ANDERSON WRITING IN
FEDERALIST ABOUT A LAST YEAR
OR SO, SAYS:
>> MOST OF IT IN FIRST YEAR.
NOW, NOTE ABLE 8.7 MILLION
DOLE DOLLAR GAP EXISTS.
SINCE HIS DISCLOSURE COVERS
PART OF 2017 WE LACK
INSIGHT.
DIDD THAT MONEY, HE IS
ASKING, GO TO JOE OR JILL?
WILL WE KNOW IF PRESIDENT
PROVIDED A COPY OF THEIR
S -CORP TAX RETURNS, ONLY
DETAIL WE HAVE ARE THOSE
GIVEN TO US BY CAMPAIGN AND
BIDENS AND THE PRESS.
WE KNOW THANKS TO U.S.
SUPREME COURT THAT WHEN
REPUBLICAN TAKEOVER THE
HOUSE THEY CAN GET ACCESS TO
JOE BIDEN'S S -CORPORATION
RETURNS, ALL OF IT.
ALL OF HUNTER BIDEN'S
RETURNS, ASSUMING HE HAD
FILED TAXES.
A FOOTNOTE, THANKS TO U.S.
SUPREME COURT, CONGRESS NOW
HAS POWER GIVEN THE FACT
THEY ALLOWED A LAME DUCK
DEMOCRAT COMMITTEE OF
CONGRESS TWO WEEKS AGO TO
GET 6 YEARS OF DONALD TRUMP
TAX RETURNS FOR NO REASON,
THERE CAN'T BE A LEGISLATIVE
PURPOSE.
THEY COULD GET ACCESS TO
NANCY PELOSI'S TAX RETURNS.
AND BARACK OBAMA'S.
AND MICHELLE, OF COURSE.
GEORGE W. BUSH, AND THEY
COULD GET CHIEF JUSTICE OF
UNITED STATES TAX RETURNS,
THANK YOU SUPREME COURT.
WHAT A DUMB DECISION.
THE DOOR IS WIDE OPEN FOR
THE REPUBLICANS TO GET
RETURNS ON PRIVATE CITIZENS,
PUBLIC OFFICIALS ANYONE THEY
WANT, JUST SAY IT SAY
LEGISLATIVE PURPOSE, MOVING
ON.
WHY AM I LAYING THIS OUT?
BECAUSE OF THIS IN THE
"WASHINGTON POST":  DAVID
BROCK RUNS MEDIA MATTERS, IS
HATE ON FOR CONSERVATIVES
AND REPUBLICAN PARTY, AND
HATE ON FOR TRUMP AND ALL
REPUBLICANS, WASHINGTON POST
POINTS OUT THERE WAS A
MEETING IN SEPTEMBER, AMONG
OTHERS BROCK AND SOME BIG
WIG ACTIVISTS ON DEMOCRAT
AND LIBERAL SIDE AND HUNTER
BIDEN'S LAWYER, BLUNT IN
LAYING OUT AS WASHINGTON
POST WRITES A STRATEGY
SESSION THEY HAVE IN
ONSLAUGHT OF INVESTIGATIONS
AND HOW THEY WILL FIGHT
BACK.
AND DESCRIBE
POSSIBILITY OF DEFAMATION
LAW, THEY PUT THIS OUT TO
THE PUBLIC:
THIS ARTICLE GOES ON AND ON,
A GROUP CALLED COURAGE FOR
AMERICA, A S.W.A.T. TEAM
CALLED FACTS FIRST AND WHITE
HOUSE, THEY ARE ALL INVOLVED
OF WHAT IS A CHARACTER IS A
ASSASSINATION
CAMPAIGN AGAINST ANYONE WHO
DARES TO SPEAK OUT AGAINST
THE BIDEN FAMILY, THAT IS
INTIMIDATION.
THAT IS ALSO OBSTRUCTING.
AN OFFICIAL EFFORT BY
CONGRESS TO CONDUCT AN
INVESTIGATION, I WONDER WHAT
MERRICK GARLAND WILL DO
ABOUT IT, THE CLEAR THE
PURPOSE TO INTERFERE WITH
OPERATIONS OF CONGRESS,
THERE IS NO NEED TO MAKE A
GENERAL THREAT TO PROSECUTE
PEOPLE FOR DEFAMATION IN
ADVANCE OF TESTIMONY.
THAT ANTICIPATES AN EVENT
THAT IS YET TO HAPPEN.
TO HAVE A CHILLING AFFECT.
TO THREATEN PEOPLE, AND
PREVENT TESTIMONY.
IF I WERE LAWYER FOR HUNTER
BIDEN, MR. KEVIN MORRIS, OR
HUNTER BIDEN, I WOULD WATCH
WHAT I SAY.
BE VERY CAREFUL, ANY
CRIMINAL VIOLATION BY
CONTEMPT OF
CONGRESS CAN BE PROSECUTED.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TALK
DOWN NAMES AND YOU FIND OUT
WHO IS THREATENING TO
INTERFERE WITH YOU'RE
INVESTIGATION, AND WHETHER
THIS GOES TO HIGHEST LEVELS
OF THE WHITE HOUSE.
WHAT IS THIS?
NIXON 2?
I DON'T KNOW, BUT THIS IS
TROUBLING, AND THIS SPECIAL
COUNSEL HOW THE HELL DO YOU
HAVE ALL THIS EVIDENCE OF
THIS KIND OF ACTIVITY OF
ENRICHING A FAMILY, A VICE
WHO BECOMES PRESIDENT, WHAT
FOREIGN GOVERNMENTS AND
FOREIGN CORPORATIONS,
SERIOUS QUESTIONS ABOUT
WHETHER THEIR TAXES ARE
ACCURATE.
THE CLAUSE WITH THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES AND WHETHER OR NOT WE
HAVE A MAN IN THE OVAL
OFFICE WHO HAS BEEN
COMPROMISED, HOW THE HELL DO
YOU NOT APPOINT A SPECIAL
COUNSEL TO
INVESTIGATE HIM,.
NOT HIS SON, HIM.
HOW IS THAT POSSIBLE,
PURPOSE OF SPECIAL COUNT
STATUTE TO NOT INVESTIGATE A
POLITICAL OPPONENT, LIKE
SOME THIRD WORLD DICTATOR,
IT IS NOT TO INVESTIGATE
DONALD TRUMP.
YOU HAVE NEVER HAD THE
APPOINTMENT OF A SPECIAL
COUNT TO INVESTIGATE A
POLITICAL OPPONENT LIKE THIS
IS SOME THIRD WORLD.
THE IMPORTANT IS TO
ELIMINATE APPEARANCE OF A
CONFLICT WITHIN AN
ADMINISTRATION, AN ATTORNEY
GENERAL APPOINTS A
SPECIAL COUNSEL.
SO THAT IS WHEN YOU APPOINT
A SPECIAL COUNSEL, WE HAVE A
SITUATION, IT HAS TURNED ON
HIS HEAD, TO INVESTIGATE
DONALD TRUMP OVER DOCUMENTS?
ED AND THE CONCOCTIONS ABOUT
JANUARY 6, HE SOMEHOW HAD A
ROLE?
YOU DON'T HAVE A SPECIAL
COUNSEL IN A MATTER THAT
INVOLVES A SITTING PRESIDENT
AND HIS TIES TO COMMUNIST
REGIME IN CHINA TO REGIME IN
RUSSIA, TO PRIOR CORRUPT
REGIME IN UKRAINE, AND SO
FORTH?
AND